michael lewis is the new york times
best-selling author of iconic books like
the big short money ball
and the blind side his new book the
premonition a pandemic story
explores why the u.s struggled to
respond to the coronavirus
despite being considered the best
prepared country
the book highlights some of the public
health experts who fought for years to
get us ready for a crisis
exactly like this one michael lewis
joins us now michael good morning to you
you've described this book as a kind of
superhero story
where the superheroes seem to lose what
do you mean by that
well you have these characters who who
had prepared
for in some cases for their entire lives
for this moment
and who saw it coming and i don't mean
it kind of in an abstract way but like
identified in in january exactly what
was happening in wuwan and who were like
a step away from the levers of power
that would have
enabled them to really take control
and they were they were fighting they
were fighting um
inside of a system that that it was kind
of blocking them every way
and the links they go to to sort of save
the country from itself
and they do save lives but but but it
it's sort of like
you can't believe people are doing this
yeah you can't believe that we don't
we don't appreciate what they're doing
so they they do save lives but not as
many uh lives as would have been
saved if the system left into action as
as you pointed out at the very beginning
of the book
we were ranked as the most prepared
country in the world for an event
like exactly like this one and yet we
have a disproportionately high number of
people
dead and dying still to this day if
people saw it
why were they unable to convince those
in power to do something sooner
you know it's remarkable that we were
judged to have the resources
to to deal with a pandemic greater
resources than anybody else and that we
had
you know slightly more than four percent
of the world's population and
more than 20 percent of the world's
deaths um i i think
and i think the answer is um that
the this particular threat i mean for
the first place if you back away
from it and i think we've let corrode
the government
sort of risk management function that we
have all these these institutions that
are there to manage these kind of risks
and we've not cared for them we've let
them fall into disrepair
and then it added to that the trump
administration didn't have a particular
interest in managing them
in the first place and didn't really get
their minds around them
but but but beyond that i mean with a
threat like this
he almost requires an extraordinary
trust in government because
you need to take action before you know
when the sky is blue
that you're dealing with you're dealing
with a an invisible enemy that
replicates
exponentially and by the time you see
you're in a mess
by the time you see people you know sick
and dying
the virus has overrun you you've lost
your chance to control it and
that was the period sort of january to
like late march
where our response you know it required
us to
sort of have a faith in our leadership
that we lacked michael
we like to believe that that we have a
great health care system in this country
but you basically say it's completely
broken and one of the
heroes of yours of your book dr charity
dean says the us doesn't really have a
public health system
it has five thousand dots and each one
of those dots serves
at the will of an elected official and
and almost everybody you talk to is also
critical of the cdc who's sort of
supposed to be the heartbeat
in the response to the pandemic why are
we so broken
well there isn't a system right i mean
it is three it is 3 000 of these local
people who
on whom the burden falls and they were
given and they aren't networked
they and they aren't and there isn't
like a lever you pull at the federal
level and everybody responds
so you've got to do it by persuasion so
that's that's one problem
but the second problem is that
the the kind of the absence of cover the
political cover that the
the the cdc was giving these local
people i mean to me one of the amazing
sides of this story
is the degree of bravery that was
required by these local officials
no one knows who they are uh no one
knows what they do
but when they do it they infuriate
people and and
what they're doing is you know saving
lives uh and
what they required was just like a
little help from above
so why is it so broken um i would say
broadly like if i'd put my finger on the
first thing
apart from the fact we haven't ever
created a proper system
but why is it so broken at the top is
that we've politicized it
that if you go back 30 40 years
the the the person who ran the cdc was a
career public servant
who who would run it for a decade or
more who had some protections from being
fired
and who had the kind of long-term
interest of the institution at heart
and it became a presidential appointee
during the reagan years
and the incentives for the person who's
there for 18 months or two years like a
presidential appointee
and and who is answering very directly
to
a political boss are just different and
it's not that they're venal
it's just that they're more short-term
it's a bit like the difference between
having
you know a renter and a house and a
homeowner yeah
it's a good point it's a good line as
well and you write many good lines and
one of the best parts of the 60 minutes
piece on you on sunday is the opening
shot
in what appears to be i guess your
writing room this semi dark space you've
got headphones on
i don't even think there's internet in
that it looks like you're in a bunker
yeah yeah no it's pretty primitive
all right that's how it's done though
you write a book as well as you do
michael lewis thank you very much the
book is
the premonition on sale today wherever
you like
to buy your books